how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in double the story I want to
start with his about a friend of mine
and I will call the friend Sam although
that wasn't his name and Sam came to me
one day Sam was an executive vice
president and other in other words a
very senior super important extremely
well paid individual he came to me one
day and he said Margaret I think I'm
going to leave my job I said wow you
know you've been there a long time
you're in this very powerful well-paid
job why do you want to leave do you have
another job no okay so what's the
problem well he said you know I've known
for about two years that one of my
colleagues sexually harasses the young
women in his department and everybody
knows everybody knows you know when we
have executive outings he'll bring one
of his latest young women along with him
you know the rest of us bring our
spouses he comes with one of these women
it's awkward it's embarrassing and I
feel ashamed of us that we allow this to
continue and I just don't want to be
associated with it anymore so I've
decided to leave and I think at that
point he expected me to say well done
Sam you are a man of principle you get
out of this place as fast as you can so
I'm going to pause the story there
because one ending of it could be sam
leaves and he gets a job somewhere else
and he lives happily ever after
but one of the things I was thinking
about is I was having this conversation
with Sam is what's going on here what's
really happening in Sam's head what's he
thinking well one of the things that sam
was thinking was I don't like this it
reflects badly on me I don't want to be
associated with it so go away that sound
thinking about Sam he's thinking it's
not my job to fix this right he's
thinking it's not my job to fix this I'm
not head of HR right sexual harassment
isn't on my job description so it's not
my job to fix it he's thinking well
maybe nobody else minds and as it
happens Sam is Egyptian so maybe he's
thinking maybe this is OK in England
what do I know he's thinking if I raise
this topic it's gonna be an argument
well I don't like arguments nobody likes
arguments I'm conflict averse most
people are conflict of us so I don't
want to have this argument it's much up
better easier to leave so it's not my
job maybe other people think it's okay
right I'm conflict of us I've tried
really hard let's say let's say for two
years to ignore it so I've stayed really
busy so that
I've kept it at bay but somehow it won't
leave me alone and and it's too
difficult it's just too difficult so
instead of doing anything I'm just gonna
leave so Sam is a textbook example of
someone who's willfully blind he's been
willfully blind for two years and he's
still willfully blind even though he can
see what's happening because he cannot
see a single positive outcome except for
him to preserve himself by leaving and
you might think Sam is an unusual
example I think he may be having an
experience it's quite likely everyone in
this room has had not exactly the same
but working in situations where there
things that aren't quite right and it's
not quite our job to do anything about
them and we might be wrong and we want
to be a good we want to do a good job
which bind me at large we think means
let's not have a fight let's be jovial
good citizens let's fit in and I've seen
this in so many cases I've kind of lost
track if you look in detail as I have it
what happened in Rotherham exactly the
same thing everybody knows everybody
knows what's going on in Rotherham if
you look at any NHS scandal everybody
knows right in bristl they knew that too
many children were dying from heart
operations in Mid Staffordshire they
knew that too many patients were dying
you could see them in the hallways so
this is a very very common occurrence
and sadly one reason I had to update my
book was because there's a whole new
books worth of
comples of people who are in the middle
of something and it's not great but they
want to preserve themselves their sense
of themselves as good people so they
want to move away from the thing that's
bad they and they want really
desperately not to see it and that's
where Sam is at this moment it's bad he
can't think of anything to do it's not
his job it's other people's jobs not
quite sure who doesn't want to have the
argument conflict is bad
turn away here's a second version of the
story Sam and I have this conversation
and I turn to him and say Sam I think
this is great I'm really delighted you
have such high standards but I think if
you're going to leave it's really
important that you leave with your head
held high so here's the question for you
have you tried everything and Sam looks
at me and he says well I don't know what
would everything be I said I don't know
Sam I don't work here you work here I
think you need to go away and take a
quiet moment with a piece of paper and a
pen and make a list of what everything
could be and think about that about a
month passes and I see Sam again and
he's looking pretty cheerful and I said
so Sam what happened how did the story
end you never told me he said well it
was really interesting I did what you
told me I did the list I wrote down a
whole bunch of things I could do or
could have done and then I looked at the
list
and there were two or three things on
that list that I thought actually
they're so easy I may as well just give
it a shot and that story ends with the
sexual harasser being fired and Sam
being promoted so which story do you
think is true the one where he leaves or
the one where he stays who thinks he
leaves put your hands up and who thinks
he stays god bless you it's nice to know
there's some optimist in the audience
Sam stayed he went and he did his list
he acted on his list and he stayed now
what is so interesting to me about the
story is it Sam had power sam had
experience Sam had intelligence and Sam
had an ethical sense
he just had absolutely no idea how to
use those things he was blind to his own
capacity he was blind to his own power
he was on some level unaware of his own
capacity get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in aaaggghhh